foreign
[Music]
hello I talked to Dr Paul this morning
he told me to bring my pigeon in
I have homemade pigeons I have three
pair that are breeding pair and then I
have uh 20 that I just let fly and we'll
come back put your glasses on your shirt
you're not outside now so I look better
with the glasses so
it's just fun just watching the bird fly
and you're waiting for them to come back
that's basically why I do it
it's sick and I I don't know what to do
at this point his neck is like bending
sideways I've never seen that before in
a picture I drove almost 200 miles my
dad used to have pigeons and he was the
one that showed me I just followed his
lead basically
Mr Paul how the heck are you better than
this bird Joe and Lisa having pigeons
and this one actually has a lot of
problems that it it can't stand up I've
never had a pigeon that looked like that
and still can eat yeah
it's very difficult but when I lay the
food down he will eat can you get
medicine in his beak so he eats it yeah
good for you good for you you're gonna
try it because you got nothing to lose
yes this is a brain problem or an
equilibrium problem his one eye is not
good so I think it's a brain problem
that he cannot even close his eyes very
good those things happen more often many
times it's either a pastoral or a
salmonella that is infecting the brain
I'm going to get your medicine and say a
prayer
I always want to try but the main thing
is if you get them soon and you hit him
happy with antibiotics and
anti-inflammatories sometimes they pull
through I've used this before it has
worked for me good it's just you know I
hope for the best
that's what you have to get into the
brain it's worth a try of course I don't
know of anybody else that would have
taken a pigeon I knew if anybody could
find what the problem was that Dr Paul
would be the one
[Music]
get your boots out of my seat
today I'm going to Henry's farm with Dr
Lisa and Dr Ray
he has two cows that have a lameness
problem the one with the horns is a
cross with the Angus and I think burnsy
I just enjoy having some cattle
so too lame cow
two days ago the one over there with the
horns I wasn't as concerned but the calf
is already losing weight they drop off
in weight because they don't get around
eating and the one has a calf and so the
calf will soon be affected by it also
well let's get one in the shoe and then
we'll get the other one
There She Goes
hi sweetheart looks like there's an
abscess down at the bottom
there's a little bit of husk drainage
this is what actually is it foot rot
would they be getting it from going
through swampy areas it can happen if
there's just a little injury lets the
bacteria in having wet feet though
doesn't help the steer has an abrasion
in between the spaces of his foot you
can feel it cracks and crevices and
smells nasty that's why my hand is
disgusting foot rot has a pretty
distinctive smell I can smell it off
it doesn't seem very diagnostic maybe
fancy like drawing blood to find out
what's wrong with them but it's usually
a pretty specific way to diagnose this
disease
what do you guys want to use I think an
oxy tip we'll go get injections we'll be
back I think I have a lot to teach the
new vets you learn a lot your first year
out how much you want to give this is
one Mig per hundred
I didn't know geez it's a big needle
we're just gonna do some antibiotics and
she's going to clear up on her own that
looks better
[Music]
got it perfect
does it feel like an abscess or just a
swelling I think she's got the same
problem yeah that's what it looked like
so so I found the same thing going on
with the cow
we're gonna do the same treatment adding
bad eggs and anti-inflammatories
she is all set we'll take that halter
off her
let her go two animals came down with
the same thing that means that
something's going on in the environment
if another one comes up with one we can
get you antibiotics for it there's a lot
of Swampy areas out here with a whole
bunch of brush so they likely stepped on
something and got infected as long as we
treat them keep an eye on them they'll
be good well have a good day thank you
thanks for stopping by
I think they checked it out well and I
expect it to clear up
[Music]
I know you are upset I've got two camels
one's Abby she's 18 years old Anna is
16. hello how are you
don't ask we're running so fast they
don't know which way I'm going these are
Dromedary camels which are the one hump
each one's got their own personality and
there's a lot of work but they're a lot
of fun to work with okay you got two
camels two camels and a Navy
TB test today TB and Bruce losses Rick
wants to start milking camels in order
to sell milk like this these camels had
to be TB tested head goes up every time
I know today you'll have some challenges
because they can't hear their babies and
they're not around yes I love you too
but don't run over me they were stinkers
getting in the trailer so it's hard to
say what might happen today
blood out of the neck if I can't help it
Abby and Anna will need a blood draw and
a TB skin test by the tail
pastel camels are ruminants like cows
this is this is good now yes don't have
to bite me either I know you do that and
you can treat them like this okay except
they don't act like cows
you see that I got it hey camels are
nice animals but they can kick with the
front legs careful I know that that's
how they kick they can kick whether hide
legs I haven't done anything yet and at
the mission that they use their head as
a club
done all right but that's neither you
know there after Anna's feisty
resistance hi girl
I got the TBN already Abby's chill
disposition it's Dr pole over the hump
[Music]
all I need is blood hi sweetie you're
fine
see this doesn't even hurt see what I
mean don't make it easy when you can
make it hard right that's right Rick
knows how to handle these camels between
the three of us we got our work done see
what I mean how's that huh that's good
I'm happy
real happy with what Dr Paul did in
three more days we can read the results
and see how they came back do they have
four teeth four just hoping for good
clean results huh see I learned
everything new so if we do sell milk
people know the milk's coming from good
healthy herd
we got some camel milk though I have
never tasted it but they say it's good
oh we got some if you want to try it
there's a lot of benefits to the camel
milk there's 52 units of insulin per
liter in camel milk which is real
helpful you know for diabetics just like
cows just like cows I tried it it was
really uh
not bad tasted pretty good
hey mom come here camel milk
oh yeah she is
how do you think it's okay
since I was brave enough to try it get
up in here
now my goal for today is to try to get
everyone else to drink it too
I drank it no thank you
[Music]
Mesa mobile three
of it
it's been a long day at the clinic okay
bring it over right now we have no
stealth veterinarians even small hands
Dr Nicole's day I will check up is about
to get a little bit longer a bit me goat
had one at three o'clock and maybe
thinks there's another one those are fun
stay for that
David and his family are bringing in
their goat marble yep there's goats she
had one kid earlier today
and nothing else since then so they're
afraid something might be stuck in there
she's had four of the last two times is
what we were told okay we're expecting
three more hi mama she still looks
really big so we're concerned that
marbles in pain maybe one of the babies
is turned around inside is she still
trying to push it looked like some
placenta came out okay
I know it's really important to make
sure that a kid is not stuck in our
birth canal
I know
hold on hold on our goat marble had her
first baby and we think she has more
inside she still looks really big
[Applause]
it's after hours and it's really
important that we see this go make sure
that a kid is not stuck in our birth
canal
she's had four babies each of her last
two pregnancies so a little bit nervous
I know she's a seven-year-old Nigerian
dwarf hardly makes any noise
she's a very sweet happy goat first off
more more in there
[Applause]
on vaginal exam I am trying to see if I
can feel anything just never like
pushing too much
I feel for any tears any abnormalities
or anything wrong with a mom
she is super tiny yes it's a good thing
Dr Bolden didn't attempt this
no I can't steal anything else okay good
because I can get my hand in there yeah
it's common for goats to have multiple
kids but there are no more kids mom's
just gonna have one where is the baby at
[Music]
my kids about a year ago they decided
that one of them wanted a dog and one
wanted to go first one got his dog right
away and the younger kid got his goat
about a month ago the here she a little
she it looked like double me though
they've been super excited about having
some babies ever since we got her
little girl
[Music]
I'm gonna make sure that she is doing
okay overnight okay um keep an eye on
baby make sure he starts nursing
prognosis for marble is great appreciate
you sticking around yeah you're welcome
we are really relieved that marble is
not in pain trying to deliver more
babies nice to meet you yeah Dr Nicole
outstanding very fast very quick glad
she was here for us
[Music]
let's go
the whole Army is coming Chris today
povet is running a four for one deal
so now we can charge you four Farm calls
pet from house farms call that they have
a cow with a D.A displaced Apple Mason
come on guys move
we strive to have healthy cows and when
doc Paul comes out here he's always very
effective the way we're doing it here is
not taught at vet school we gotta teach
them they all do surgeries so I'm
bringing Dr Nicole Dr Lisa and Dr Raya
so I can show them how to do it
holy cow we got a bunch of animals in
here
surgery is a lot harder on the cow than
rolling them on their back and stitching
them
to avoid an intense and costly surgery
whole vet Ducks treated D.A a simpler
way so Dr Pol really likes doing the
flipping Stitch slip and Stitch flip and
Stitch hello Hi how are you good good
watch out we do a flipping Stitch to
help put one of the stomachs of a cow
back in place okay here you can see it
feel the bump there this cow has a
displaced Apple Mason and can see it
from here
the Apple makes them as a stomach that
normally is only filled with water but
if the cow goes our feet it can fill up
with gas and it floats to the top there
you go I got it watch out let it fall
sometimes the cows run lucky and they
have Mason flips out of position and
causes a little twist it's really
uncomfortable so we need to fix it
man she felt right too I know I told you
in order to get the stomachs back into
place and keep it in place you roll the
cow
and when you roll the cow on their back
that gas pulls the stomach back in place
this is where you always have to suture
listen quickly everybody but you listen
for it is a certain pinging sound
just like what you call a basketball a
basketball being bounced
hear it okay there's only one spot where
it should be stitched feel that you can
twirl the needle around
it has to be that loose the whole secret
is you cannot do it tight you don't want
to get the stitches too tight some slack
plenty of slack and always leave a head
width loose like that if you put it
tight they die don't ask me why
okay turn the loose
now watch the switches they should
tighten up so when we roll the cow
through then you can see that the
stitches pull tight are they yep yep see
and then you know darn well that you got
the stitches in the right place and the
stomach is attached to the belly wall
always in that spot guys okay
that cold brought Three Vets here today
and he's very thorough on making sure
that they saw what was going on with the
cow see ya okay guys okay thank you
thank you yeah it's four vets for the
price of one today so
[Music]
foreign
so I don't know how it happened but half
her paws got a slice right across it I
went to feed the horse tonight and the
one cat wasn't around she came in
limping but what led back leg it almost
looks like a fan but I don't have any
vehicles that have fans it's almost cut
right to the Bone if not cut to the Bone
it's cut really bad it looked like
mangled
it's cut really bad
Bridge has little Barn cats back as for
somebody is not other we got his hand
leg caught someplace
this is a bad thing
Friday she was okay though because she
was out by the campfire all night long
it's a barn cat but she's my favorite
one in the friendliest one and it rides
around the farm in my side by side
actually puts her paws on the front near
the steering wheel hopefully he can fix
it so her Paw's intact
[Music]
I am still going to try to save it okay
I figured it's if it's 50 but it's still
warm okay okay okay good thank you doc
you better I figured it was going to
have to be amputated right off the bat
tell them to keep it here okay thank you
cut toe I'm going to try to sew it I'll
be very happy just as long as she's
healthy
come on sweetie Dr Paul will try to
repair what's left of Spec's paw none of
the pads are damaged to speak up see
that like they say if it ain't broke
don't fix it
go ahead
that looks good
[Music]
that was tendons
a closer look reveals the full extent of
the damage I thought there was more it's
mainly skin like yeah the tendons are
gone yeah what was hanging out of the
foot or the toes that were so mangled up
there was no way that we could selfish
them
it's one good toenail so ever cut that
off and save some skin from here
I can pull it over and he has one that
will heal up then you cut one toe left
three of Spec's toes are Beyond repair I
thought I could save it and I looked at
it first but it's thinner than what I
thought it was amputation of the injured
toes will spare Spec's leg leaving her
with a one-toed paw
yeah that looks good Andrea thank you
the best way I think is just to cut that
mangled piece of foot off
okay
shoot it up
that looks good
perfect he'll be hopping along and
everything should be fine okay go ahead
black nose is very good you know put
them on the antibiotics and usually in a
couple weeks everything is healed up
yep
so that's a one-toed cat
spec can easily get around on three and
a half legs like this and has no problem
moving catching mice
foreign
[Music]
because some of these cows cows are wild
come on let's go watch out watch out
watch out watch out of the dozens of
cows that need to be checked scared that
the Jeepers out of you huh few will be
easy
all these cows are beef cows that means
they are in the pasture many times all
year round
they don't like to be caught
these animals are free roaming animals
and they like their freedom ready There
She Goes
watch out she's coming through here hey
they have a fall day but they sell and
beef cows from all over the state but
the buyer has to know whether they're
pregnant and whether they are pregnant a
long time or a short time I gotta start
digging here like a gold mine
because it all depends how much food he
has to keep these cows through the
winter
three
three months but three months is close
enough but a pregnancy check them and I
call out a number that's the month they
are pregnant this little thing is
already five months pregnant you can
tell that there are many owners of these
cows some cows are in very good shape
and pregnant oh she's pregnant oh come
on around the corner there you go it all
depends on the owner how he's feeding
them she's gonna have a fall calf six
and a half how much pass should they
have or if they got anything extra in
the past it must have been good because
you know these cars are all in good
shape
[Music]
yes when we were called they thought he
had 30 to do but by the time we got
there it has grown to 65.
but it was very smooth because everybody
knows what to do last one
and you know it's fun work
I love working at the Claire livestock
already we'll see ya
foreign
[Music]